hey guys how's it going so today for
tech Tuesday I'm gonna be unboxing the
Amazon echo tap and this is a portable
bluetooth speaker by Amazon and it's
basically a portable small version of
Amazon Alexa let's take a little peek
now what's cool about this is if you are
on the go it's great for streaming music
if you're connected to Wi-Fi but it's
basically is a small Alexa at least
that's kind of the gist of what I've
read online do that do this I'm a huge
fan of when I travel I usually bring one
of the Bose Soundlink minis with me
because I like to be able to listen to
music in the hotel room kill the iPhone
speakers aren't really like a look at
this little baby Harold sooo I'm
supposed to come with a portable
charging dog I believe
looks like it uses micro USB to charge
which is fantastic I absolutely love
things that I can charge with USB
because I hate bringing so many extra
chargers with me so I've got a USB
charger and access to USB port I can
charge my device it feels funny I don't
like the feeling here's the little dock
place you're gonna learn device on the
charging cradle to setting your device
download the Amazon Alexa mmm please
hold your mobile device wasn't paired in
your Bluetooth settings first forget
your Amazon device and then try pairing
again Hey
put yourself back on ready to pair go to
the Bluetooth settings on your mobile
device and choose Amazon - to q.q that's
what I'm that's what I meant it to it
okay great follow the instructions in
your Alexa app ok this is perfect it's
got audio input it's got Bluetooth Wi-Fi
what more could a girl want set up this
complete like music here's a prom
station you might like Cruella
really good kids between the Amazon
Alexa names on tap as you don't have to
say Alexa do this it is called tap
because you actually have to tap the
button it really thought about this one
what's the weather right now currently
in Los Angeles at 73 degrees with clear
skies tonight you can look for mostly
clear skies with a low of 61 degrees
all right cool I will tell me a joke did
you hear about the two thieves who stole
a calendar they each got six months
don't have to weigh in here hmm can you
tell me another joke
why do elephants paint their toenails
red why to hide in cherry trees I'm not
this I feel like this is like these are
jokes that nadeshot would help tell me
another joke what do you call an
American revolutionary who draws
cartoons why ain't you doodling
oh god these are just really bad ah this
is pretty cool I'm kind of excited about
this I'm going to show you in comparison
to the Soundlink mini so hold on a
second so this is from bos this is the
Soundlink mini 2 and this has pretty
much been my favorite go-to I travel
with this almost all the time and of
course like I said this is the Amazon
tap if I had to say they feel about the
same weight the Soundlink mini feels a
little bit heavier but not by much I did
notice that they have different types of
Caring
travel cases I really think it was
necessary but now that I'm looking at
this I feel like it needs to have
something protecting it the Soundlink
mini
is a little bit taller they're about the
same would sound like many also has
audio input this also has audio input
what makes this so cool is the fact that
it is kind of a smart device so if it is
connected to Wi-Fi you can ask your
questions I read online that the
batterer
lasts about nine hours which i think is
a pretty fair battery life for a speaker
I guess I'm not really sure what the
common battery life is looks like
Soundlink mini 2 is 199 dollars I
believe this is a hundred and seventy
nine anyway thank you guys so much for
watching if you want to check this out
on Amazon not sponsored link is in the
description you could also check out
Amazon Alexa which is really really neat
and also Amazon dot Annie other speakers
into smart speakers haven't got that yet
I don't think it comes out until May but
I'm not sure I'll see you guys the next
tech Tuesday hope you guys enjoyed this
video and I will see you in the next one
bye
this was actually this Tuesday actually
Tuesday I think it might be